well from this season's preview we
learned a lot
just from the preview when it comes to
you hazel we learned that you are
bisexual
but you felt as if you had to hide it
living in the philippines
how did it feel to finally come out and
own that now that i'm here and
i am free like i am free being
who really i am i'm glad because
finally i found a guy that really accept
me
and especially my son
and now i'm not shy
for being me we've definitely seen a
transformation because when we first met
you hazel you were shy
you know and very to yourself and now we
see you coming into your own so it is
really beautiful to see i will say that
blooming
girl it's a work in progress but you're
doing a great job
yeah all right well um tariq speaking of
hazel saying that you accept her for who
she is
what was your initial reaction when you
found out that
she's into women as well well you know
it it was sort of a mixed bag for me
i learned early on um you know
hazel and i had been chatting for a
couple of weeks and then you know she
was like okay
listen before we go any further there's
something i need to tell you
you know and i want to be upfront and be
honest with you or whatever i thought
she was gonna say
i'm married you know you're gonna have
to beat up my husband
you know to get me in you know so i'm
like sweating
what is it she was like okay she's like
what if i told you i like girls too
and i'm like okay do you mean literally
like she's like yeah what if i told you
you know i like men and women so okay
um that'd be
nice and i was like okay so what does
that have to do me
she was like what if i wanted to have
you and a girl
i was like then i would be the luckiest
man with too long breathing
on earth i mean let's keep it all the
way real here
so um you know but more than just
the obvious yeah you know hazel
told me that she had kind of kind of
went through some
you know some drama about it with her ex
because he did not accept
you know and he basically told her you
know that
you know she was just a walking body of
sin
and you know just really hurtful stuff
and you know that i think further made
hazel kind of close up
you know and never want to tell anybody
again you know she's not knowing
wrong you know or whatever you know so
when she told me
um i was like well i'm glad you
you know felt the need to tell me
upfront
and not only do i not care
i want you to be yourself i don't care
what anybody says
speaking of that we see in the teaser as
well
you helping hazel find a girlfriend
what what what is the good fiance to do
you know okay
so the big question here tyrique is
is this a girlfriend just for hazel or
would this be a girlfriend
for the both of you now if i told you
that you wouldn't
watch what you got to tell us something
though because this is look this is what
everyone is wondering is this a throttle
or is this just hazel having a friend on
the side
this is this is hazel and i together
letting hazel be himself
that says a lot that says a lot and that
being said
do you ever have any concerns tyrique
about hazel potentially
falling in love with another woman and
choosing to leave
your relationship who would leave
somebody that blinged out tarzael how
are you gonna leave that
you can't leave that look it's a
potential though
so i just want to know your thoughts has
that ever crossed your mind has it ever
been a concern
absolutely not and the reason is you
know hazel and i have been together
two and uh well we've been together some
years now
and we have been through
more in two years than the average
couple would go through in 10 years
i mean so um
i mean we have had serious ups and downs
so we really know each other and
you know why would i even go into it if
i doubted that
yeah you know so sometimes you have to
throw caution to the wind
and i feel like she you know
gave up way more than i did
you know i mean she basically turned her
whole life upside down till he can get
here
so for me to say oh you're going to fall
in love with a girl and run away with a
girl
you know what kind of man would i be i
got square shoulders you know everything
is in the right place right here
okay well i have to ask hazel her
thoughts on that i mean
this it sounds it sounds simple and like
an adventure and all but
it can get sticky you know bringing
someone else into
your relationship it can get sticky so
hazel
have you ever had any concerns about
you know maybe you might enjoy another
woman's company
more than you enjoy tyrex
my concern about having
a girlfriend one day is
sorry you know because i want him to be
fair yeah that's my concern so you want
him to be fair what do you mean by that
fair like um
yeah you mean that
if it gets to a place where
we're married and we have a girlfriend
that you want me to treat
you and her fair yeah okay so that just
made me think of something else that i
mean this is this is new to me like
that's why i'm curious
you know i just want to learn do you
ever have a concern hazel that
tyrique might want to spend more time
with that woman
than you or fall in love with her
um don't you because that's
[Music]
you can already knock my arm off
um my concern in the future
is if derek fall in love more
in the girl i think
sometimes that would be hap that will be
happen
right am right you mean that you think
so it's a possibility for it to happen
yeah no of course not
it's not possible um i know
everything everything is possible you
know when you're doing something like
this but
you know when you know you know
um you don't know what's coming you
don't know
tomorrow but one thing i do know
one thing i do know and you know this
for sure
that i put you in front of everybody
else
so why would the future be any different
okay i'm gonna take your word tariq
you know the fans will come for you if
something changes
hey listen listen i got y'all i got
y'all
you see you amended the names can't go
no further than that
yeah well hats off to you all because
this is a sticky situation
but i wish you all the best when it
comes to that 90 day fans have their
opinions so
is there anything you just want to set
straight or just let them know about
your relationship
before the season begins yeah yeah yeah
just
just well especially after you know
people were just hearing that hazel's
bisexual for the first time
he wants a girlfriend what does that
mean you know
um you know y'all are just
uh she's just giving you you a license
to cheat
right no hazel is bisexual
she likes men and women
hazel is here you know for us to find
out if we're gonna make it
to the altar that's why she's here
and i'm here for the same reason